hello everybody hope that you're good
it's been a great trading week and the
best thing is that I've been able to
share with you my plans and my triggers
of of this trade and yeah it played out
very well so um I also try to update you
in a daily basis so you knew uh my
thought process every day if I was
entering if I was adding size to my
position if I was exiting which is the
case of today I just exit and take
profits of of for my position for
several reasons that I explained in this
video and I also think that now that the
projection is finished we can focus on a
different trade setup so that's what
this video is going to be about we're
want to try to have um broader uh view
on the market especially in high time
frame um so we can start to understand
different type of setups that we can be
looking from next week and then of
course in a couple of days on Sunday
I'll post a new H plan a new setup for
the week ahead that it may play out it
may not play out but uh what matters is
that you know we have uh an actionable
and tradable plan that has predefined
risk so you know um as long as you have
more wins than loses then you're going
to be a profitable Trader so that's what
this is all about it's not normal and
don't expect that this kind of
projections happen every single week
because they don't don't you know but
anyway let me explain all of these so in
the last video what we were saying is
you know in the daily time frame it was
right after this event here this very
long week this drop that we saw from
100K all the way to 90k in one day 10%
drop and I was telling you you know
don't panic be chill because so far you
know we are in a Range look at this this
been going for already 4 months
so you know it's nothing to worry about
that's the range lows that's support and
as long as you don't see some kind of
breakdown from the bottom of this range
then you know we are safe we are still
going to continue trading this range for
some more time or at least that that's
the way I'm trading this you know it's a
range nothing else so based on that we
was saying that was very likely that
some weeks go we're going to get filled
in the case of ethereum we want to go
through that later uh most of those long
weeks got filled and now we're kind of
seeing this relief H pump this recovery
which is pretty normal considering all
the liquidity that is to the upside and
we're want to go through that right now
look at this guys the first thing I
notice here is this purple line is the
4our 50 you can see that we've been
testing it a resistance for a long time
look all these circles are back in here
these are resistance retest you know
that's a fake out over there that's
another one there there and basically
when you have you know an EMA I use the
50 ma when you have it acting in into
such a strong resistance then Traders
are going to see this and they're going
to start to place their shorts short
position you know scalpers day Traders
short in the 4our F because they're
thinking you know if he was five times
before six times seven times before the
eighth time is also going to be
resistance and eventually what you are
getting there you know what it is you
are getting a lot of stop losses and
liquidations in this area here you know
that is full of liquidity and that's
what is happening right now you know
this this recovery that we are seeing
right now this move here that's
basically what it is they are hitting
those retail Traders stop losses and
liquidations and you know I've posted
the heat map on on X but yes there is a
lot of liquidations and exactly 99k they
are getting heat in this exact minute
you know we're at
98.9k those liquidations are getting hit
right now and is what I'm telling you
guys you know um is not only trading
what you see but also what you don't see
so yes you are seeing that the 4 or 50
May is acting as a strong resistance but
you are not thinking or most Traders are
not thinking all the liquidity that you
can't really see right above it so
that's what you can expect this sort of
um long well short squeezes in this case
and that's what got me on Sunday with
this idea of this recovery to the
mid-range okay um now why was I
expecting you know to hit
93.3k exactly what we hit another range
lows basically because I could see some
liquidations to the downside at exactly
93.3k also you know it was a sweep of
the lows and because we've been testing
the 4 8 for such a long time I was
expecting more of this recovery so I was
not forecasting a bigger drop also I
said in the bitco date if we drop to the
range lows it's very likely that we
don't bounce okay it's very likely that
we continue dropping towards
88k why simply because you know if you
want to go to the range lows that's what
we did before you know there is no other
reason to go to the range lows other
than continue dropping all right that's
what we got that very long week there it
was not like this case you know that it
was a drop very sustainable another
sustainable drop no look at this drop
from here that drop it was simply to go
back to the range lows okay so there was
no reason to do that again
except to continue going lower that's
what I thought you know that higher
low would be more likely all right now
uh you know midrange is getting hit this
projection we can get rid of it so let
me get it out of your eyes there it is
we go again a naked chart we can say
liquidity pull to the upside that means
you know that there there is a sort of
Interest test above the current price
and the reason why I close my long
position here at the mid-range is
because it could act as resistance okay
also it's possible that you know we stay
here at
98.9k and we don't continue pumping $100
more which is like
0.1% simply because maybe the market
wants to do a run of liquidity okay and
in this move here I don't want to hold
hold you know a position and not close
my current long that's for $100
difference it doesn't make any sense 0.1
0.1% is nothing compared to the 7% we've
been trading from the lows okay so
that's what I flows my long
position1 $200 right before hitting the
mid-range uh again it could we could
continue pumping you know hitting the
midrange but I didn't like that
possibility that risk uh that I would
was saying however there are two ways
that I could get back into a long
position the first one is if we can
reclaim the mid-range not over the
weekend okay because I don't trade
Bitcoin over the weekend it's not
volatile enough for me so I will like to
see this over the next week so if over
the next week in the weekdays we can see
Bitcoin getting back above the mid-range
that is telling me okay that's not
resistance now it's support we can
continue going higher towards this
liquidity pull at 105k toward this range
Highs at 106k or 7K all right so that
would be a long trigger that I'll
probably be explaining the Bitcoin to
the date so you got a little spoiler now
H based on you know High time frame View
and the other possibility is that if we
don't hit the liquidations at 99k today
which seems very um you know very likely
that we actually go all the way there so
this case is less likely to happen but
look at the one on50 may we haven't
really tested it since 95k 96k all right
so if we actually draw from here back
into the 1 hour 50 Ma I'll be looking
for a long scalp today okay back to 99k
but again that seems qu likely because
we're only $100 difference it's likely
that we just do this boom end of the
case all right so uh just a little
possibility there for you in case we see
this right now okay I would like to Long
scalp this to finish the the trading
week now that's pretty much everything
for Bitcoin in terms of trading I'm not
looking for shorts I'm looking for Longs
cuz I can see momentum do know getting
back up of the 4 Hour 50 ma now in
higher time frame what we've said we in
a Range we can see here also some
support but the weekly 50ma is cre
upwards which that's what I think we you
know consolidating in this range and I
think it's very healthy because it's
letting the weekly 8 to catch up with
price that then you know could act as
support and then price continue going
higher the only thing that it doesn't
woring but but the only thing that makes
me a bit nervous is this CME Gap that we
can see a
77k however it doesn't mean that we're
going to you know that we're going to do
this it doesn't need to get filled
immediately you know sometimes they can
take months years to get filled so we
could continue with the bull run and
then in the future you know drop towards
it but if it was the if it's the case
that we're going to fill the C gap
before well during this bull run and not
in the next B market then I don't think
this would happen okay I think something
like this it's more likely right that at
least we push up first then go to the C
Gap okay instead of dropping first to
the C Gap um I think this is very
unlikely that happens this is a bit more
likely and also it's very possible that
we just continue going higher and then
in the next Market you know fill the C
Gap so uh that's the only thing that
really makes me a little bit nervous so
yeah that's
for Bitcoin in in general we'll talk
more about it next week look 99k got hit
there you go mid-range is stacked so yep
all the short liquidations have been
hit and now I'll be sitting on my hands
for the next few days until Sunday
evening where I'll be posting Bitcoin
soon up
date I don't think it would be crazy you
know if we pump higher today
okay and then over the next week we have
this retest then that's what I will be
looking to Long all right so we'll talk
more on Sunday cuz we I don't know what
is going to happen today my trading week
is finished so you know I'll be updating
again on Sunday then in the case of
ethereum you know what to the Daily time
frame we we saw this crazy huge week
here and I posted right after closing
this daily candle you know it's likely
that we drop again towards 2,500 cuz
that's where the 50% of the of the week
is um we filled I think 45% of the week
around um
2,520 so uh that's normal and I said
also that you know it doesn't need to
get filled exactly 50% % sometimes with
40 45% is also done you know we're not
going to argue for
5% so the way that I've traded this it
was uh basically at this point saying on
Twitter you know for me the week has
been filed and then here you know I've
got myself the confirmation you know it
seems like we're not going to drop again
so at
2,620 30 that's what I bought some more
ethereum in a spot you know to DCA
and right now what I'm seeing here and
you'll be able to see here also is quite
clearly is that that that white dotted
line could act as resistance you also
got the daily 50ma there so I would
really like to see ethereum you know
pushing higher towards 3,000 then there
at 3,000 we'll see what happens okay the
same as with Bitcoin if we get back
above it then continuation to the upside
this liquidity pool can get fill well
can get retraced
3,700 potential continuation to 4,000
all right but if we push towards
3,000 and we have the daily 50 Ma and
this classic resistance level and also
psychological exactly 3,000 remember so
there is going to be a lot of you know
people selling there also some uh short
Traders you know trying to s that level
so
if we see a rejection from that level is
it still possible that we continue
feeling this long week okay it's
something that I see less likely I think
that for that we would have to see
Bitcoin dropping towards the um you know
range lows again but I think it's more
likely that we see that kind of reclaim
here and continuation but can thism the
idea of a rejection and continue filling
this week and if that is the case then I
have the here at 2 2 200 between 2,200
2,100 I have more limit orders in a spot
to buy ethereum all right so that's the
way I'm training these in the long uh in
the long term so let's
continue well the ethereum and Bitcoin
dominance least to see some recovery
here okay so nothing really talk there
the Bitcoin dominance is quite
interesting so if you guys guys remember
I was
calling for my top to be exactly let me
Mark it for
you so I was Maring exctly at 61 point
no 60 61.
55% okay that's what I called my top we
hit it perfectly slightly above it I
think we're going to 70 61
70 we have the drop here I was expecting
some kind of a lower high but I was
quite scared you know that this time I
could be wrong and we actually broke the
previous high you can see there we have
a long week to to fill so it's possible
you know that we F that week but if we
fill that week and we get back below
this level you know perhaps yes perhaps
that's the top level and then it can to
go lower
so seems quite confusing right now but
yes we're right now below resistance so
it's not looking it's not looking that
bullish it's looking quite bearish the
Bitcoin dominance except the part that
we have a long we to the upside so at
least we should R it you know
62.8% or so very likely and then see
what happens from there if we hold this
level then continuation
Alin then would continue dropping okay
and if we see that we getting fail the
drop back below this resistance retest
then drop okay um pretty much we have to
wait a bit more to see what happens then
the
S&P daily time frame the S&P is very
bullish keeps making new all-time highs
every week you know and if you can see
quite an organic growth you know keeps
testing well keeps going up then re then
retrace up retrace up retrace
continuously doing the same thing you
know um you can see how the daily 15 is
acting a
support um for right now you know it's
not looking bad at all why couldn't it
continue doing the same okay why not so
yeah the S&P is not telling me
anything exciting really now the the
dollar Index is the dollar Index is
because since Donald Trump going into
the White House is been dropping since
the 15th of January you can see there
it's been going down let's see if it
gets back inside this range because the
Range High here you know it's a level of
support so we could see some kind of
Bounce there but if we drop inside this
range below the range highs then it's
possible we drop all the way to the
range lows and in this time you know
that benefits crypto because you know
Bitcoin trades against the dollar Index
you know that's why you have Bitcoin and
the dollar pair the dollar pair goes
down then Bitcoin is going to go up okay
so uh
well that was take it that take that
with a pinch of salt because it doesn't
happen all the time but as a general
rule you
know and let's see what else we can talk
about yeah the AL Market what's
happening with the Alin market
so you know the there is something
happening in the Alin market and is that
in the FC minutes this week they've
announced that um well they've announced
they've done a survey
and as an average it came that it's
possible that they finish that they stop
QT by summer of this year now what that
means for Al coin is that from a
historical point of view in the
charts there is there has never been an
old season during QT right now we're
doing QT so that means that it's
unlikely to see an old season but if
they stop qt in summer then that leaves
the door open for an old season from
then okay so um if that's the case if
that happens then maybe the FC members
change their minds hopefully not but if
that's the case and they stick with this
then you know
once they stop QT it's possible that we
start to see some more movement bullish
movement in the ALCO market and it now
QT doesn't mean that QE is going to
start and QE is not necessarily bullish
for the AL Market you don't need QE to
be um bullish in the AL Market just as
long as there is not QT you know as long
as the QT stops then the AL Market is
going to have more chance
to to do well so that's pretty much
everything um it says okay but again
let's see what happens in the other time
and I don't want to make this video too
long I just wanted to give you a heads
up on what is happening with Bitcoin a
bit how I analyzed this week so you
could understand my thought process and
also my view on the high time frame
again there is no need to to Panic or to
sell your bags that's at least what I'm
thinking right now you know we're in a
Range so you know you could have a break
out or a break it and just wait for to
see what happens but during the
range you know it's not bad at all so um
let me know guys if you want me to
upload a video about the ALCO Market
maybe we can chart some alins there are
there a few Alco charts that I'm looking
at so if you guys are interested in that
then let me know and next week I can
upload a video and based and focused on
the Alin Market on different alins in
fact tell me in the comments some alins
that you want me to chart um we can go
through them and before I finish this
video I want to announce that you know
I'm partnering with bluffing and we are
releasing a new campaign you know we are
doing campaigns pretty much in a weekly
basis H you know to give you some
rewards for trading there for support
for supporting my content and basically
there is now a campaign going on that
you know know anybody that registers
under my referral link and you know you
can do any deposit or you can do $11,000
you can do a deposit of $10,000 up to
$50,000 doesn't matter the amount and
you're going to get a 10% cash back all
right so uh you're going to get that in
Futures bonus so make sure that you
deposit your funds into your futures
wallet so you can get that bonus of 10%
and then also based on your trading
volume you know we are going to give you
some rewards in USD that you can
actually withdraw so pretty much it's
you you are doing what you do usually on
byb on binance on any other exchange
that is trading just trade but here
instead you also going to get some
rewards some us that you can withw and
you know with the funds you deposit
you're also going to get uh 10% cash
back of what you deposit so um I think
it's a great opportunity for everybody
and we do this quite often so you won't
only be participating in this one but
also you know once this campaign
finishes will release a new one so you
can constantly get some rewards on
trading and it doesn't require kyc so it
takes a couple of minutes to sign up and
also if you have a bluffing account with
another
influencer uh and you want to transfer
it under mine you know to support my
content then uh you can you don't need
to create a new um a new account you can
simply dend me your
uid that you can see in your profile and
we can transfer that in in a couple of
minutes right so that's it guys a bit of
a promo there thank you so much for
supporting my content thank you so much
for watching and I'll see you soon